more than 300 homes have been destroyed
on the spanish island of la palma by a
river of volcanic lava gradually making
its way to the sea
everyone was safely evacuated after the
island's volcano began to erupt on
sunday but they've been left to watch
from a distance as their homes disappear
a mass of molten lava dangerously close
to swallowing up this village on the
spanish island of la palma
up close this formidable wall of burning
rock towers over buildings threatening
the lives and livelihoods of those below
i feel powerless because we can't do
anything because we know that there's
more to come
we're not big franchises we live off the
people who are losing everything if they
lose we lose too
thousands have been evacuated and
spanish prime minister pedro sanchez has
assured them they will be safe
but with people's homes and businesses
up in flames the need for basic items
like food and clothing is growing
hundreds of supermarkets companies and
volunteers have banded together to try
and fill the gap
there's been an avalanche of solidarity
from the people of la palma but also
from the rest of the islands and from
the mainland
people haven't stopped contacting us
wanting to know how to send donations
fear that the lava whose temperature is
more than 1 000 degrees celsius might
reach the sea causing explosions and
spewing out clouds of toxic gas
authorities are also warning that
earthquakes acid rain and volcanic ash
could threaten the safety of local
residents
the eruption could go on for months but
prime minister sanchez has promised that
the spanish government will not rest
until everything that was destroyed by
the volcano is rebuilt
you